there's substantial empirical evidence  showing that cheap federal loans are  actually a major cause of the rise in  college tuition which has outpaced the  growing cost of even medical care and  housing this theory was famously argued  in a 1987 new york times op-ed by then  secretary of education william bennett  who wrote that increases in financial  aid in recent years have enabled  colleges and universities blithely to  raise their tuitions confident that  federal loan subsidies would help  cushion the increase when you give  people more money to pay for something  prices tend to go up and forgiving debt  makes the problem worse students don't  care as much if college administrators  overcharge for their services because  they'll probably never have to pay it  back anyway  [Music]